where you
going I'm Aya Stark I'm going to kill
queen
Cersei the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of aon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget but
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
season 8 video in this video I will go
over what one of Game of Thrones actors
said about the show's ending during
their recent interview I found this to
be very interesting because they finally
revealed what they wanted to happen
during Game of Thrones final season Game
of Thrones actress Lena heiti shared how
she wanted Cersei Lannister's story to
end she actually revealed the dream
ending she had in mind for Cersei and
Jamie Lannister's final scene now some
of you might actually recognize ized the
idea she had in mind because there were
a lot of fans who wanted this to happen
as well it was a theory that everyone
was sharing before HBO aired the final
six episodes it involves Cersei Jamie
and another fan favorite from house
Stark now back in 2019 Lena heiti
revealed how she was not happy with the
last season of Game of Thrones because
she did not love what happened during
cersei's final moments on the show if
you ask me Cersei was wasted during the
final season because she basically set
on the sidelines for most of the
episodes well in her new interview she
gave more insight into how she actually
felt about the show's ending when she
admitted what she really wanted to
happen in cersei's final scene the Emmy
nominated actress said her dream ending
would have been for Arya Stark to
surprise Cersei by confronting her while
disguised as her lover SL brother Jamie
she also said I think all of us cast
members had ideal endings in mind for
our characters to be honest and that's
because you start trying to write the
story yourself and Maisy Williams and I
would fantasize about of Cersei and
arya's Showdown that she would come back
as Jamie I would have loved to see the
look on cersei's face while she's
sobbing as the red keep collapses around
her she would have had a sudden but
short moment of relief as she discovers
her lover and brother Jamie has arrived
to hold her during those final moments
only those feelings would have then
immediately evaporated when she realizes
Jim's actually there to wrap his fingers
around her throat it would have been so
much more satisfying to watch her die
thinking it was actually Jamie who ended
her life life now imagine the fan
reaction when Jamie walks away from her
dead body only to then remove his face
and reveal himself to actually be ARA
Stark I find it interesting that Maisy
would have liked this ending also now
some of you might remember when all the
fans were discussing this Theory before
the show aired its final season there
were a lot of fans who wanted to see
Arya Stark use her faceless men's skills
to wear Jaime's face sneak into the red
keep then end Cersei Lannister's life it
could have made for an amazing scene
because it would have brought together
so many different aspects of the show
obviously we finally would have seen
Arya wear another face something I think
most fans wanted not only that but it
could have also fulfilled the valenar
prophecy by having jimie albe it in a
roundabout way murder his sister it
would have been a much better death for
Cersei and jimie as well I don't think
there were very many fans who liked how
jimie and Cersei died we also could have
avoided that dumb scene where Jamie says
he did not care about saving everyone in
King's Landing so I do think this would
have been a better option than what Dana
Dave gave us not to mention I almost
forgot Cersei was also on Arya Stark's
Hit List
Joffrey
Cersei Walder
fry
Marchant Taiwan
Lannister Arya would have been able to
scratch another name off that list it
would have made so much more sense than
having Arya defeat the night King as we
all know the night King was never
directly connected to arya's story story
she did not even know the army of the
Dead existed until season 7 it was Jon
Snow who was connected to their story
from the very beginning when he
volunteered to join the kns watch in the
very first episode if you ask me this
was always meant to be Jon's Destiny he
wanted to join the knight's watch to
guard the Realms of men from what lied
Beyond the Wall he was the one who
gathered everyone together to fight them
in the end he was also the one who had
face off after face off against the
night King yet Dan and Dave thought it
was a better story to have defeat him
her journey from the very beginning was
Vengeance for her family that's why she
made the list after all the night King
was never on there your list of people
I'm going to
kill johon should have been given the
night King and Arya should have been
given Cersei unless jimie killed her or
Arya did it wearing his face as we all
know Arya was already right there with
the Hound imagine if they walked up
those steps together while inside the
red key the Hound searching for his
brother while Arya stalked Cersei
Lannister it would have been a double
whammy because Cersei and the mountain
both were still on arya's
list we come across my
brother maybe we can both cross a name
off a
list now after Lena heiti reveals how
she and Maisy Williams wanted the show
to end she says that was our J dream but
they went in a different direction she
did clarify how she understands the
show's creative team was under a lot of
stress with the final season adding I
think in hindsight everyone understands
you're in it and you've been so invested
there's a moment of why but I absolutely
get it she then goes on to say she also
moved on from the franchise as a whole
revealing that she can watch House of
the dragon as it's just too weird she
noted how she doesn't miss the show
itself but she misses everyone that she
used to work with and had gotten so
close to over the years you know as I've
said before Game of Thrones actors will
continue to reveal more of their honest
feelings about the show's ending as we
get further and further away from those
final episodes we've already heard so
many other actors admit that not loving
how Game of Thrones ended I hope more of
the actors will say how they actually
wanted to show the end rather than only
saying they didn't like it as you can
see by the interview she said I think
all of us cast members had ideal endings
in mind for our characters to be honest
because you start trying to write the
story yourself and Maisy Williams and I
would fantasize about Cersei and Arya
having a showdown that she would come
back as Jamie I would love to know what
ideas the other actors had in mind for
their endings hopefully we will find
that out one day let me know what your
thoughts are about this new interview
would you have rather seen this ending
or do you still like the original leave
it down below as always I want to thank
each and every one of you for watching
this video I hope you all have a great
day I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]